come back we look now to a trial
captivating the nation as defendant
Daryl Brooks represents himself in the
Waukesha parade Massacre trial out of
Wisconsin
six people were killed and dozens were
injured when prosecutors Say Brooks
rammed his SUV into the annual holiday
parade last November officials say
Brooks continued to drive even after he
hit multiple people and others banged on
the hood of his vehicle for him to stop
he now faces 76 charges in connection to
the crash before the trial began Brooks
elected to represent himself declaring
he is a sovereign citizen throughout the
trial he has noted he does not answer
into the name Daryl Brooks on Wednesday
he attempted to subpoena the state of
Wisconsin as a way to face his accuser
Brooks argued that under his rights his
accusers should be a quote living
breathing human being
you have simply put on here state of
Wisconsin plaintiff that's an entity you
have to name a person sir you have to
have a person named sir so that they can
come and testify you only have an entity
named
is it uh not true that under the Sixth
Amendment I have the right to face my
accuser
the state Mr Brooks has simply written
the word state of Wisconsin plaintiff
for the witness name
state of Wisconsin is an entity it's not
a person the state of Wisconsin cannot
testify at these proceedings every
document that was filed in this matter
stated that the state of Wisconsin was
the plaintiff which would lead me to
believe that the state of Wisconsin
is
who's bringing the claim against my
client
how could they not be subpoenaed to
testify if they're the plaintiff
Karen Brooks is right in a way he along
with all of us have certain rights under
What's called the confrontation clause
of the sixth amendment but is he arguing
it correctly
absolutely not and we can I guess we can
forgive him for not having the um wisdom
to know how to argue these cases before
or this particular case before the court
but there's legal principles behind it
and he has to follow the law and the
judges indicating you you take this risk
when you represent yourself and this is
where he would hugely benefit from
having the advice of counsel which he's
uh denied uh he doesn't need that so
when he comes up with these um arguments
and he doesn't have a way to refute them
and he has no way of explaining or
someone to explain to him how to do it
in in the appropriate way that's the
situation that he's facing it is as a
court indicated and entity as well as
the prosecution you name have to name a
particular person in order to call that
person as a witness and he told it
totally uh missed the mark in this
regard and he's not
able to maneuver his way through because
he doesn't have the knowledge yeah let
me help you out Daryl Brooks the Sixth
Amendment says that you have the right
to confront Witnesses against you to be
president in court and to cross-examine
them it's not necessarily an accuser
like a state but Terry Brooks is even
trying to subpoena the state of
Wisconsin what do you think of this uh
and what is his thought process you know
there's no question that attempting to
subpoena the state is a stunt by Brooks
just like everything else as far as I'm
concerned I know he's claiming he is a
sovereign citizen but if you think about
all of his objections and the fact that
you know he doesn't want to be called by
his name and he's arguing that the state
has to come in and once he said the
state has you know thousands of people
and is he expecting all of those people
to come in he didn't name all of them I
mean it's a stunt he's just I think
delaying and trying to you know make a
record for appeal yeah we'll see maybe
the state of Wisconsin will be there for
the Appellate case well switching now to
Texas where an ex-police officer is
charged for shooting a 17 year old boy
who is eating a hamburger in a
McDonald's parking lot it happened on
October 2nd in San Antonio Texas
shocking body camera footage shows
ex-officer James Brenner fired 10 shots
at the boy as he begins to drive off at
the time Brenner noted that the vehicle
was the same one who had sped off during
an attempt to stop the night before body
camera video shows Bernard opening the
car door to find the shocked 17 year old
when the boy puts the vehicle in Reverse
Brenner fires multiple times the driver
identified as Eric Cantu was shot
multiple times and is in critical
condition a 17 year old girl in the
passenger seat was not injured Brenner
was fired from the San Antonio Police
Department last week for violating
Department tactics and training
procedures
coming up on Law and crying daily we
head to Ohio for the latest developments
in the Pike County Massacre trial plus
the prosecution continues to call
witnesses of the deadly crash but for
the first time one points a finger at
the defendant that's ahead a long crime
daily
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage
now in the Waukesha parade crash trial
for the first time jurors hear from a
witness who identified Brooks as the
driver of the SUV that crashed into the
holiday parade
I could only see one person in the
vehicle presumably
yes it was on the driver's side front
driver's side could you tell
yes it was a black male
and at the time I the eyes is what drew
me in were completely wide open and
um you made eye contact with with the
individual driving the vehicle so you
looked eye to eye with the person who
hit your your daughter I did do you see
him in the courtroom today I do can you
point him out by were you seated and
what he's wearing
take off his face mask
thank you
he is seated at the table located over
here he's got a gray suit on a blue
shirt and a tie
Terry Brooks is identified as a
defendant in the court interestingly
enough when they say Mr Brooks take off
the mask he knows it's him but he says
he doesn't know who Daryl Brooks is does
that affect the trial or is that just a
sovereign citizen argument
it's definitely a sovereign citizen
argument and I don't think it will
affect the trial or at least it should
not listen half the time he answers to
the name Brooks and the other half the
time he objects he's objected so many
times on the record and it's unclear
what he really wants to be called he is
saying he is and you know a sovereign
Citizen and he's saying he's a third
party intervener and you know he talks
about the fact that you know my client
my client but the court has to address
him the court has to say you know Mr
Brooks overruled or Mr Brooks sustained
and sometimes I've noticed the judges
even called him sir so I think the
jury's listening to all of these names
that he's been called and all of the
names that he doesn't want to be called
even the pronunciation of his name and
so I don't think they're going to take
it very seriously at all they know who
he is and he was just identified yeah
Darrell Daryl it's all the same thing I
think at this point but Karen all eyes
are on Brooks at this trial but how is
the prosecution handling their Witnesses
I believe the prosecution is doing a
really good job I it started with um
introducing first of all giving the
proper respect to Mr Brooks uh as in a
as the person is representing himself as
the attorney so there's no disrespect I
think they're being very cordial very
being very respectful and they're
putting forth their Witnesses in a
chronological order first they put
forward the uh law enforcement officers
and then each witness uh step by step in
terms of what happened that day and I
think it makes it very easy for the jury
to follow and I think that they're doing
a very good job of presenting their case
to the jury absolutely I don't think
they're distracted by any of this kind
of song and pony dance that's going on
on the defense table well switching to
Georgia where officials are trying to
piece together what happened to a
missing Savannah toddler one thing marks
one week since Clinton and Simon was
reported missing the 20 month old was
last seen in the morning of October 5th
near his home home in Savannah Georgia
federal agents have been brought in to
assist Chatham County officers in the
search officials have seized evidence
they say will help move the case forward
but gave no specifics to any details
about the evidence on Wednesday morning
the Chatham Police Department posted to
social media they would be at the boy's
home with a team of search dogs and
investigators authorities say the
investigation will go on despite the
long man hours
this has got to be exhausting you can
tell you you look tired how your
investigators doing this is a tough case
thank you thanks for that question I
appreciate that um they're they're tired
but they're determined
I couldn't be any problem
they have worked 18-hour days since last
Wednesday
along with the FBI and everybody else I
mean everybody is they are all hands on
deck they are committed they are working
hard to try to bring a resolution to
this case
if you know anything about Quentin's
disappearance please contact Chatham
sheriff's office at the number on your
screen